thing is cool when you're part of the
team everything is awesome
the one-time daycare teacher and former
business consultant can dance he's also
lego's ceo and a savvy salesman the
media will soon report that his company
earned a billion euros in profit last
year lego celebrating its own success
this is really one of these days where
you wake up in the morning and say yes
everything is awesome because it is our
10th consecutive year of growth
which is
something that i think is really unique
and very unlikely for any company to
achieve
this japanese television team has come
from tokyo to film inside the production
facility
lego produces 60 billion plastic bricks
annually it's a simple product that's
popular with hundreds of millions of
children and parents
last year lego had 4 billion euros in
sales
even though computers and tablets are
children's favorite playthings these
days
a reporter says legos are selling better
than ever before in japan
many parents are thinking of all
the kids needs you know
remain things creative imagination or
something like that so
many parents are focusing refocusing to
a lego just broken blog and
making imagination something like that
so
that's a kind of a contrast
legos were invented in the danish
countryside
in billand which has a population of
seventeen thousand a master carpenter
began making blocks and other toys more
than eighty years ago and it developed
from there
today lego continues to drive the local
economy
the crew moves to the company museum the
visitors learn that lego is an
abbreviation for the danish words lego
or play well
since 1959 the company has focused
production on themes like the post
office and mail delivery or city streets
in the 1990s lego tried to earn more
with bags and clothing than it did with
toys but they almost went broke and had
to rethink their strategy
a plan that was supposed to pull the
company out of the crisis and
narrowing down and focusing on the brick
was
the main part of it
then in 2004 mckenzie manager jurgen v
knowsdorp took over the company and
pulled it back from the brink
lego rationalized cut personnel and
products and came up with a successful
merchandising program
and he tried a pink lego line designed
for girls
now he's setting his sights on asia
companies building a new factory in
china
you're not afraid of losing quality
not at all uh you know we have been
building factories in hungary czech
republic that used to be located in
places like switzerland and denmark we
also still have a factory here in
denmark and then we build a factory in
mexico monterey and our experience is
because we do 90 or more of our
manufacturing in-house in factories
controlled and operated by us that we
can have absolutely the same
safety and quality standards in our own
factories regardless of where they are
if we can find the locally qualified
labor
but simple building blocks are nothing
without a story to go with them
around 120 designers work for lego
one of them is elizabeth crawl of
germany
we've got this little bambi here that
you can see in any wooded park
but if you show this model in asia it's
really exotic because there aren't deer
right around the corner
that's exotic in germany but more
commonplace in china
yeah
this is on the echo
the japanese tv crew is heading home
loaded down with their lego blocks
this time it's a big customer target
adults in other words who have big plans
for their very own legos